John McClane always been with the
Houston Chronicle since the 70s since
1976 to this very day
he's been 43 years at it love when he
chats on the show good to chat with you
John what's going on in your world rinse
all kind of things great time coming up
with the NFL I'm added Astros spring
training as a fan for three days this
weekend to watch them play I want to see
them play on the road because I'm
curious about how they're being treated
in spring training games compared to
when regular season starts their first
road trip is at Oakland you guys were
talking about Brady if indeed he went to
Bruce Arians areas would have to change
his entire offense he sends out
everybody doesn't keep Titans running
back said the block breaks got a
mediocre offensive line to me the
Raiders if he's going to leave there the
Raiders with the ideal assuming Phillip
Rivers goes to Indianapolis to be
reunited with Frank Reich at Knicks
Arianny but the Raiders have everything
but a really good wide receiver and with
their first sticking around first round
they would have their choice maybe of
all three possibly with the last to the
top two after somebody like Arizona took
seeding lamb
there's no question that the Raiders are
set up with two first rounders again
they're ready to cashier in there the
last from the Bears for Khalil Mac and
they had Mayock pone the trigger on it
last year and he found a ton of young
players that did so well from obviously
Jacobs in the first round Abram would
have been had he been healthy max Crosby
later in the draft Hunter Renfro as well
Farrell at the very top so there is all
of that there for Tom what why not New
England though John frum based on what
you're hearing money could be a
commitment of more than one year could
be that he's concerned about the talent
he could lose to offensive linemen in
free agency you know they've tried to
bring in receivers Josh Gordon Antonio
Brown they backfired to kill Harry's
going into his second year who knows out
he'll turn out really haven't replaced
the Gronk he doesn't have the kind of
talent
on that offense that he could get from a
team like the Raiders infinity the
Raiders were interested in radiant of
course that would mean they'd trade
Derek Carr but everybody's talking about
Tennessee I know Tennessee watch Teresa
Ryan Tannehill and if indeed he doesn't
if he prizes himself out of their market
then they can go ahead and play brady
hope he can come in there and have a
chance to win a championship I was next
to you you put any credence in the 49ers
is a possible landing spot John Jimmy
Garoppolo misses 2018 when the torn ACL
he comes back he helps them go to the
Superbowl
people say well I've read this and heard
this rich boy Brady would have made
those plays at the end of beat the
cheese Brady didn't make plays at the
Inka Dinka Titans at home so I'm sure
Tom Brady would be great for them for a
couple of years but they're committed to
Garoppolo I'd be stunned if Kyle
Shanahan pulled off the deal where he
signed Brady and maybe they trade
Garoppolo back to New England so a
handicap it for me one week from
tomorrow
new league ear opens up where do you
think Brady goes I'm gonna say
handicapping goes back to New England
one Raiders psycho Titans third what
about the Chargers you don't think
they're in the mix your offensive line
is awful the last place he needs to go
is some team as an offense applied that
needs to be totally redone what about
the idea you don't want to go in mahomes
his division right now imagine Tom Brady
would care about that he's the greatest
of all time he probably like a chance to
show mom's it's kind of like the old
gunslinger was one last rodeo shoulders
boss but I think the problem with the
Chargers is in fact people don't care
about him in LA is their offensive line
Brady has got to have a good offensive
line that's imperative
your ear to the ground on the collective
bargain agreement you've been through
many of these rodeos
John how do you see this playing out now
that we've got two extra days for the
vote to take place the NFL Players
Association selecting a new president
today I mean one talked about so many
moving parts franchise tag
window has just been moved the deadline
to noon on Monday which is when the
tampering window opens up with a new
league gear coming oh my gosh
it's a big conversation with this
collective bargaining room and so much
about what happens next weeks hinges on
this but what are you hearing rich I've
been through multiple strikes that's not
good for anybody the owners always win
elders run football as you know the
Union runs baseball and basketball and
it's not going to change because there's
so many players and when you have 60%
making 1 million or less they're the
ones that are going to benefit the most
right off the bat I think it will it
will it will pass it's not 11 other year
could change a lot of things about how
much money is spent because the players
won't get as big a cut the rosters won't
be increased practice squads won't be
increased but I'll say this I think that
whoever is the next union president when
he takes over and you got a 10-year
agreement that's kind of job you and I
was shot we had no well JC Treader was
just announced as the new Players
Association president right is there is
there any handicap Winston did a
terrific job reg it was it boy after
difficult circumstances and and I don't
know what's next for Eric he could go
into TV to go into radio politics work
for the leg work for the union but I
think Eric's not a tremendous job okay
John McLean here on the Rich Eisen show
what is the deal with Verlander he's
already said he doesn't think he's going
to be ready for opening day or what
what's the scoop on that front he's
having two injuries and you know he's
been healthy since he had serious groin
injury with the Tigers in 2015 and the
Astros Achilles heel is their pitching
staff not just losing Gerrit Cole but
Lance McCullers coming off corner Tommy
John surgery he'll be limited they don't
have anybody step up after that now if
you have Verlander say after the first
month of the season cost him three or
four starts a crank he's got a step
he's old too and their undoing could be
the pitching staff but you know rich the
last thing you can do with a 37 year old
starting pitcher is bring him out back
too soon so I expect they're gonna they
will wait until he's 110 percent so we
may not see him till May yeah that's
what that sounds like to me too
when you're talking about cold weather
where you might go I mean you mentioned
the first road trip is is in the Bay
Area in Oakland I mean what the the the
coldest winter ever spent was this
summer in San Francisco right could you
imagine what it is in April like so
that's that's the whole you know why not
just sit somebody till then the concept
that I hear from so many fans John is
that the seating scandal won't go away
anytime soon and you wanted to know what
their reactions gonna be on the road
it's gonna be quite something when their
first road trip is in Oakland and also
here in Southern California with the
Angels fans no doubt ready to hoot and
holler that so many fans are saying that
this cheating scandal won't go away
because the Astros have not been
sufficiently remorseful I will place
that in the hands of somebody who's been
there since day one watching this whole
thing unfold I'll see people like a rod
saying that and I'm saying what planet
if you've been on their first spring
training day they had that awful news
conference with owner Jim crane it was
terrible but after that they let the
media come into the locker room and
player after player stepped up and said
yes we did we're sorry and then they
told them after that you're not talking
about anymore and so I don't know what
else people want unless it's blood but
yes it's not going away I'm going up to
the Rangers news ballpark and watch them
there because that's their biggest rival
and there'll be a lot of Astros fans
there too I expect your fans like I'm
sorry to get you they don't go to New
York play the Yankees till late season I
know I'm sorry they're not playing it
out the Dodgers but the all-star game is
in Dodger Stadium can you imagine the
greeting the Astros know we'll get
so the fans are the ones in the media of
course that won't let it die for at
least a season well I mean we're still
waiting on what the Red Sox may or may
not have done the year after and and
then just the question is you see you
see enough online John with the trashcan
banging and the whistling and that the
hand clapping potentially about what did
happen in the postseason that's just
gonna be another thing that's lingering
out there at some point what did happen
and against whom specifically for us to
try and determine just how valuable this
this plan was that they had with the
trashcan banging this on stealing I'll
say there's rich people believe
Manfred's investigation if they T didn't
17 but they don't believe his
investigation that they did not in 2019
when they lost four World Series games
at home including the seventh one and
people are going to believe what they're
going to believe I can't wait to see how
the Astros handle it mentally you know
what they need to have a psychiatrist
sitting on the bench I believe so after
every at-bat they can go in there and
get some guidance but yeah it's gonna be
something that we've never seen
unprecedented that's why it's going to
be so exciting and interesting I mean
they used to have a psychologist or
psychiatrist or somebody who knew that
an AJ Hinch sitting there on the bench I
mean that's part of his you know his
education coming into being a manager
how is dusty handling all this so far
Dusty Baker is as you can imagine reg
you know he's been tremendous it's just
what they needed steady hand on the
rudder and he doesn't dodge anything he
confronts everything head-on I think I
think Harry hiring Dusty Baker will be
their best free agent move of the
offseason I hope he does well enough to
have that second year option picked up a
couple more minutes left with John
McClane I've been with the Houston
Chronicle since 1976 finger on the pulse
of Houston sports are the Rockets having
second thoughts on trading Capello been
going on I guess there's six seven and
under plan so far Rachel I was hoping I
could get away where you wouldn't bring
and bring up the Rockets for
everything's even more negative
lost four in a row they went to Boston
they had a great game to beat the
Celtics and then they just fallen flat
they're getting blown out it looked like
they quit in their last game against
Orlando and people here are baffled
they're angry the small ball that was
working so well is not working and my
D'Antoni's kind of at the end of his
rope James hearts not played well and
Russell Westbrook is so they got too
much talent not to get it together but
truthfully once they get the playoffs I
don't see this style working much past
maybe the first round right now they
look like they keep playing like this
they want him get the playoffs were you
surprised that Bill O'Brien gave up the
play calling a couple weeks ago stunned
it was the last question I asked him and
a little private get to before he went
in to do his news conference with the
masses and I said by the way though have
you given up any given anymore regard to
having offense coordinator Tim Kelly
call the plays he hesitated said Timmy's
calling the plays and that was big news
in Houston because so many fans and
media wanted him to do it now he'll be
able to focus on the game more he's
giving it up one time to former
offensive coordinator George Godsey in
2015 but every one every other year in
his six years with the Texans he's
called the place well you're one of
those many members of the media that
I've seen it owners meetings in the past
do you think this one's going to go down
in a couple weeks I do it's interesting
because they say the elderly is the most
susceptible to have to getting a
coronavirus well most of the owners are
elderly
I'm elderly and so yeah I'm going I
think they'll pull it off maybe they'll
make a stand six feet from them like
they're talking about in baseball
basketball and soccer and hockey but
it's it's unprecedented times for us
rich we got to roll with the punches we
can't worry about each of us
individually we got to worry about
what's good for the masses and I don't
mind the inconvenience at all what about
the
of not letting members of the media in
the locker room you've obviously been in
locker rooms for over 40 years do you
think that this is gonna stay put from
now on and be used as if you will an
excuse or a cudgel to keep media out of
the locker room genre or what I think
they'll do it now to be hard to complain
about it if they think it's better but
on the other hand can't let any sponsors
come in there you can't let any fans
come in there and so if it's just a
player sanctuary keep everybody out
including media hey we gotta roll with
those punches rich John thanks for the
time always love our chats you be well
okay Reggie - thank you very much as
always right back at you that's John
McLean